aquí tenemos la molécula de
ciclopentadieno analicemos la para ver
si cumple Los criterios para ser
aromática Así que empezaremos con el
primer criterio contiene un anillo de
orbitales p que se traslapan
continuamente Bueno si analizamos estos
carbonos de aquí este carbono tiene un
doble enlace por lo que tiene
hibridación sp2 y por lo tanto tiene un
orbital p libre lo mismo pasa con este
carbono y lo mismo pasa con estos dos de
aquí Así que esos cuatro carbonos tienen
hibridación sp2 sin embargo si veo este
carbono tiene hibridación sp3 eso es un
poco más fácil de ver si continúo
dibujando algunos hidrógenos
ya que este carbono de aquí tiene cuatro
enlaces simples tiene hibridación
sp3 lo que significa que ese carbono no
tiene un orbital p por lo que el ciclo
pentabieno no es aromático viola el
primer criterio no contiene un anillo de
orbitales p que se trazan continuamente
ya que viola el primer criterio podemos
continuar y decir que el ciclo
pentadieno es no aromático
por lo que ni siquiera debes preocuparte
por el segundo criterio no cumple con el
primer criterio para ser aromático sin
embargo el ciclopentadieno tiene una
propiedad interesante es extremadamente
ácido para un hidrocarburo De hecho
tiene un PK a de aproximadamente 16 para
uno de estos dos protones que dibujé en
Amarillo debería de haber algún tipo de
estabilidad asociada con la base
conjugada para que el ciclo pentadieno
sea tan ácido si pensamos en una base
que viene quizá un par libre de
electrones y una carga negativa
simplemente una base genérica tomará
este protón de Aquí
dejando estos dos electrones atrás en
este carbono de arriba
si continuamos dibujando la estructura
de la base conjugada tenemos nuestros
electrones pie Aquí y ahora tenemos un
par libre de electrones en nuestro
carbono de arriba lo que deja esto
cargado negativamente aquí está la base
conjugada y debe haber algún tipo de
estabilización relacionada con esta base
conjugada por el hecho de que el
ciclopenta bieno es muy ácido recuerda
que entre más estable sea la base
conjugada más ácido será el compuesto en
este caso la estabilidad extra está
relacionada con el hecho de que este ión
es aromático y podría no verse de esta
manera Porque si observamos este carbono
de arriba este carbono de arriba Aún se
ve como si tuviera hibridación sp3
porque es un carbanón no obstante Ese
par libre de electrones puede participar
en resonancia si tomamos este par libre
de electrones y los movemos acá eso
mandaría estos electrones de aquí a este
carbono
si dibujamos
una de las posibles estructuras
resonantes para esto
continuaré dibujando y mostrando que
estos electrones se han movido hacia acá
estos electrones ahora están en este
carbono de aquí y tiene una carga formal
de -1
y luego tenemos estos electrones pi aquí
así Ahora si analizamos este carbono de
arriba
ahora podemos ver que de hecho
tiene hibridación
sp2 en esta estructura en resonancia se
ve como si tuviera hibridación sp2 y
este par libre de electrones en magenta
está ahora ocupando un orbital p porque
está participando en la resonancia y de
hecho hay más estructura resonantes que
podrías dibujar no vamos a hacer eso en
este video aquí solo intento Resaltar
que los electrones en magenta el par
libre de electrones en magenta participa
en la resonancia por lo tanto Ese par
libre de electrones está de hecho
deslocalizado y ocupando un orbital p en
el anillo y por lo tanto ahora tenemos
un anillo de orbitales p que se
traslapan continuamente
aquí a la izquierda ya hemos dicho que
estos carbonos tienen hibridación
sp2 Y si piensas en estas estructuras en
resonancia puedes tener todos esos
carbonos en ese anillo con hibridación
sp2 por lo que cumples con el primer
criterio tienes un anillo de orbitales p
que se traslapan continuamente
analicemos este año un poco más
utilizando nuestro círculos de Frost si
continúo y dibujo a nuestro anión
con una carga formal negativa
cuando Busco electrones pi en esta
molécula usaré este color aquí aquí hay
dos electrones Pi y luego 4 electrones
Pi y luego hemos visto que este par
libre de electrones participa en la
resonancia este par libre de electrones
ocupa un orbital p y esos Ahora son de
hecho electrones pi así que tenemos un
total de 6 electrones pi tenemos 6
electrones pi para este anión y hemos
visto ahora que todos estos carbonos de
aquí
tienen hibridación sp2 cuando dibujas
todas tus estructuras resonantes
entonces cada uno de esos carbonos tiene
un orbital p y puedo dibujar
orbitales p en este diagrama tenemos
cinco carbonos en el anillo
cada carbono tiene un orbital p Así que
hay cinco orbitales p en este anillo y
puedes ver que esos orbitales p en el
anillo pueden traslaparse para
deslocalizar esos electrones por lo que
el traslape de esos orbitales p
satisface nuestro primer criterio
contiene un anillo de orbitales p que se
traslapan continuamente tengo un total
de 5 orbitales p y sé que esos orbitales
p son orbitales atómicos
5 orbitales atómicos de acuerdo con la
teoría o m
Me darán 5 orbitales moleculares y puedo
representar esos orbitales moleculares
en términos de su energía en mi círculo
de Frost
continuaré dibujando esta línea aquí
cuando hace círculos de Frost Recuerda
siempre empezar desde abajo un anillo de
cinco miembros significa que trataré de
inscribir un polígono de cinco lados en
mi círculo
intentaré dibujar un pentágono aquí
veamos si podemos hacerlo
pondremos
esas líneas aquí así Y luego puedes ver
que aquí está mi Pentágono inscrito en
mi círculo
nuevamente Lo importante es donde ese
polígono interseca con mi círculo eso
representa el nivel de energía de mis
orbitales moleculares
Y entonces puedes ver que tendré tres
orbitales moleculares enlazantes
aquellos por debajo de la línea central
y dos orbitales moleculares anti
enlazantes de esta manera necesito
llenar mis orbitales moleculares con mis
seis electrones Pi y entonces
continuó poniendo mis 6 electrones pi
así
y puedes ver que he llenado mis
orbitales moleculares enlazantes análogo
a tener una cáscara externa
completa y tengo la regla de hooker
tengo 4 n + 2 electrones Pi y otra vez
podemos ver eso usando este diagrama de
energía
aquí estarían los dos electrones y luego
4 por 1 así que n es igual a 1 aquí Me
Da un total de seis electrones pi Así
que este John satisface ambos criterios
contiene un anillo de orbitales p que se
traslapan continuamente también tiene 4
n + 2 electrones pi en el anillo Y
entonces esta base conjugada de arriba
es estable porque es un millón aromático
que es la razón de que el valor de pka
para el ciclo pentadieno sea tan bajo
Aunque el ciclo pentadieno por sí mismo
es no aromático este ión de aquí Resulta
ser aromático
lo que explica la estabilidad analicemos
un guión más tenemos el catión ciclo
heptatrienilo Y si estoy buscando mis
electrones pin tengo
2 4 y 6 electrones pi en exterior y un
total de 6 electrones
cuando Busco carbonos con hibridación
sp2
todo lo que tiene un enlace doble todos
estos tienen hibridación sp2 y luego mi
carbocatión de aquí en este carbono
tiene también hibridación sp2 por lo que
todos los siete carbonos tienen
hibridación sp2 lo que significa que
cada uno de esos carbonos tiene un
orbital p
Es un poco difícil
dibujarlo aquí Pero puedes ver que cada
uno de mis siete carbonos tiene un
orbital p lo que lo hace relativamente
fácil para que esos orbitales se
traslapen en mi anillo para deslocalizar
esos electrones pi por lo que se
satisface mi primer criterio un anillo
de orbitales p que se traslapan
continuamente
siete orbitales atómicos y nuevamente
esos siete orbitales atómicos me dan
siete orbitales moleculares que puedo
representar usando mi círculo de Frost
voy a mi círculo de Frost y dibujo mi
línea divisora entre mis orbitales
moleculares enlazantes y los anti
enlazantes y ahora que tengo un anillo
de siete miembros necesito intentar
dibujar un polígono de siete lados en mi
círculo de Frost y este es probablemente
uno de los más difíciles de dibujar
veamos si podemos hacer algo que se
aproxime a una figura de siete lados
dentro de mi círculo
algo así me da una figura de siete lados
y otra vez nos importan los puntos de
intersección porque representan los
niveles de energía de mis orbitales
moleculares
y ahora es fácil ver que tenemos tres
orbitales moleculares
enlazantes y
cuatro orbitales moleculares anti
enlazantes así y llenaremos nuestro
diagrama con 6 electrones pin nuevamente
los electrones llenan los orbitales más
bajos primero
podemos cuidar nuestros seis electrones
pi así y puedes ver que hemos llenado
todos nuestros orbitales moleculares
enlazantes
Esa es la estabilidad extra que va de la
mano con que un ion sea aromático n es
igual a uno cuatro por uno me da cuatro
más dos Me Da un total de 6 electrones
pi
Y entonces ambos criterios se han
cumplido tenemos un anillo de orbitales
p que se traslapan continuamente que
está aquí esto de la izquierda es
nuestro primer criterio este es nuestro
anillo y luego Tenemos también 4 n + 2
electrones pi Así que el catión ciclo
heptatrienilo es aromático este es un
catión aromático
Podemos esperar algo de estabilidad
extra asociada a él